Amica and Tom spun the big wheel to
enterprise I guess is the big wheel that
they spun Annika got seventeen Tom got a
number that was fifteen more than a
Macca's number what number did Tom spin
and try to pause the video and figure it
out on your own so what I like to do is
I like to write down what they tell us
and then and then think about what what
what might make sense so first of all we
have Amica they tell us that Annika and
Mika got a 17 when she spins the wheel
so Annika got a 17 this is Emma cos
number right over here she got a 17 now
what about Tom so Tom Tom
they tell us Tom got a number that was
15 more more than Emma cos number so did
Tom get a higher number or a lower
number than Amica well Tom's number is
15 more than amicus so it's going to be
a larger number this is gonna be a
Micah's number plus 15 so 15 more than
17 so it's Emma cos number it's going to
be 15 more than that so notice 15 I'm
reducing blue 15 more than Emma cos
number well amicus number 17 15 more
than that is going to be 17 plus 15 so
what's 17 plus 15 going to do B so I can
calculate it right over here so I'll
line them up so 17 is one ten and seven
ones and fifteen is one ten and five
ones and five ones and I'm going to add
so let's first look at the ones place so
seven ones plus five ones
well it's going to be twelve ones so but
twelve ones is the same thing as one ten
and two ones so I could write the two
ones down here and then I would write
the one ten up here another way you
could think about it is I just carried
the one 7 plus 5 is 12
I wrote the two
here I carried the one but what I'm
really saying is look 7 plus 5 is 12 12
is 2 ones and 1 10 and now I just add up
to tens 110 plus 110 plus 110 is three
tens so it's 32
so Tom got a 32 and you should always
check to see if that makes sense it says
that Tom got a number that was 15 more
than a Macca's number well as 32 15 more
than a Macca's number is 32 15 more than
17 sure discs because 17 plus 15 is 32
that's how we figured it out